小哥 我看完你臉書啊
對你好崇拜喔
怎麼了
因為我覺得你好孝順好孝順喔
都常常曬什麼東西啊
曬漂亮的女生
曬我媽是嗎
對 看起來一個是你媽媽
一個可能是太太的媽媽
就月母
對啊 你很常帶他們出去玩耶
對啊 要曬孝順
我覺得臉書應該要常曬這種東西啊
不要曬名車啊 名錶 沒意思
不要曬什麼名模啊
名模
没有名模这种东西
所以我们要摆扇校围先
因为快要母亲节了
所以我们要赞扬妈妈的好
可是啊
我跟你讲台湾女生也很奇妙
就是我们一边赞扬说
男生孝顺最好了
可是要结婚的时候就会害怕
他跟他妈妈好好哦
对啊
有的人择偶条件是什么
父母要双王
这很怪啊
不行
孝顺还是很重要
但是小哥有人封过你这个封号吗
我是妈宝
没有
没有人封过
不过我觉得
妈宝两个字听起来好像还不错
可是在台湾好像不是一个
不是一个好的字
就是小时候有唱过嘛
有妈的孩子像个宝
对
可是怎么浓缩变妈宝
好像就不好
妈宝好像不好
好像被宠坏
对
对啊
可是我觉得当妈宝贝很幸福啊
尤其是我们看到这种年纪
像我这年纪的
妈妈来见她就觉得
哇好幸福
对
所以我们今天要来颠覆
妈宝这个观念
怎麼說呢?歡迎收看我們今天的理財達人秀
歌有仇必報喔
那今天要來講什麼?就是
媽寶對你來說是不是一個比較負面的名詞呢?
可是在股票市場
如果你是一個有媽媽顧的股票的話
不得了通常會一飛沖天喔
然後呢有媽媽顧的小孩真的很幸福
那因為快要母親節了
所以我們今天來製作一集就是
母親節選股特輯喔
如果有賺到錢的話
記得對媽媽好一點喔
給媽媽吃好的好不好
讓媽媽帶漂亮的
給媽媽穿最美的
我們今天做的一切
就是為了要讓我們的媽媽開心喔
所以今天的特輯非常重要
從籌碼來看
哪些股票有媽媽在顧
哪個媽媽比較好
好
我們先來看
我們先來看哪個媽媽比較好不好
第一個
小哥你喜歡哪個媽媽
哪一種媽媽比較好
對
開放型 呵護型 專性在
感覺都還不錯啊
對啊
像我妈妈她也蛮开放的
对我而言
怎么样的开放
我觉得她很开明
我觉得制作人这个用词很奇怪
开明型妈妈
她可能想到开放型妈妈
开放型妈妈
开放型妈妈不错
这个开明
或者是呵护型
对你也很好
像我妈妈她对我也蛮开明的
对我也蛮呵护的
哇塞
他对我也蛮专心栽培的
所以就造就了人中之龙小哥
对
现在你赚的钱全部都要给妈妈
都会啊都会啊
我妈妈也是我的员工之一啊
她每个盘中会帮我看一下
看一些东西
真的假
真的啊
妈妈也会看
每个月都会发月薪给她
哇
对啊
那这样子她就觉得还不错
所以她是筹码之母就对了
对
太厉害了
她还蛮会看的
她盘中都会看那些
所以小哥你对张三期
是妈妈的成功
妈妈也帮助了一部分
好
那来看这个开放型妈妈
下面有小字
是投信
妈妈其实是投信
因为我们都会讲
投信任养嘛
对
就像妈妈这个
扶养我们一样
扶养我们
投信任养
那开放型妈妈呢
她是投信单日买超高
哦
她就单
只有偶尔买一下
偶尔买一下
对
后续不一定
哦
妈妈就偶尔管你一下
偶尔关心你一下
偶尔关心一下
那平常可能就又不见了
这样子
妈妈可能工作很忙
对
叫单日型
好
那贺务型呢
哇 投信连续买
这个叫小心宠坏
对
贺务型可能就是从小
哇 一直买到很大了
后面你可能要注意
不太好
从小如果你都一直把它捧在手心
捧到大有时候反效果
对
那专心栽培型呢
哇 这种就是
买股票就要找这种
就要找这种
投信买超占成交量高
要注意这是占成交量
妈妈很英才师教的
专心在照顾你
给你的都是你要的
没错
股价又在低档
还是小朋友
对啊
长大的可能是妈妈对你一直栽培
三四十岁好像栽培好像有点晚
是这个意思
好 从小栽培
哪一种妈妈比较好
有三种
那妈妈在这边代表的就是
投信任养
但不是每个任养
你都会成长
一定要挑对妈妈
对
好
我们来挑妈妈吧
怎么说开放型妈妈
或者开明型妈妈不够好勒
举几个案例
来看第一个
5月4号
5月4号单日上市公司
投信买超排行
我每次都看这种排行
我每次看
我怎么从来没看过
大力光在上面
他妈妈去哪了
外资买超
投信买超
自行商买超排行
你都看不到大力光
你知道为什么吗
为什么
因为大力光太贵了
太贵了张数不会多
没错啊
因为他们都是买超瓜都是张
这个好像有点盲点
那如果它很便宜就喷出
所以每次看到都是便宜的股票
友达 旺宏 开发金 华通
真顶好像贵点
真顶KY蛮强的
我昨天就看到真顶
真顶比较贵的
那这种呢你适合买贵的
你说如果买超排行里面要找贵的
要找贵的 你不要找便宜的
你找太便宜的
它可能就是因为它便宜
本来买的张署就可以买很多
但是贵的还买这么多
这个可能有梗
贵的就是那种
含金汤匙出身的概念
本身身价就高
对
那你看这个友达
友达便宜
这个七八块买3000张
感觉好像很简单
就体质可能比较不好
养它会比较辛苦
对
所以像这种
我们来看友达的状况
那友达呢
各位看一下
好 他遇到的是开放型妈妈
对 友达投信就昨天买而已
就5月4号买
5月4号买一个三线张
那前一天没什么买
偶尔买一下
对 偶尔买
那友达这投信利不利害呢
投信有利害的跟不利害的
所以你要看这档股票
投信过往的战绩
怎么看呢
我怎么知道这个妈妈
过去利不利害呢
那你就看
他大买的时候是高点还是低点
大买是低点
这个妈妈厉害
那假如大买是高点
这个头信可能就算怪的
对 我觉得它只是沾光
就例如说在学校考第一名
最高杀地
他就来称赞一下
我好小啊 我疼
都是我栽培的都考第一名
平常没什么在理
一脚跌下来
哎呀 你这高是一样
就修理它
所以你看这个
在上面的时候
股价高档的时候
我头信大买
所以他买错了
对不对
那股价低档的时候
头信又挺损
这种他买不大一根
他不是真的很了解他的孩子
对
他只是
他抢的时候
哎呦
隔壁有买
那我们要赶快来买一下
明天我们绩效书给他
有个头信会有这种问题
就是跟别人
因为别人绩效好
他刚才用跟的
可是跟的又太慢了
对
這種比較型的就不愛
像友達這一檔你看
中食戶就比較強
中食戶是賣在高點
而最近第一檔又買回來
所以乾媽比較厲害
對 乾媽我們就要跟中食戶
所以每一檔的投信的能力不大一樣
你可能要看一下太放心媽媽看來不給力囉對 因為你不夠了解自己的小孩所以偶尔才买一下或是之前他买的时候都是高点卖的时候都是低点好 这样投信其实你不能跟哦
对 好 呵护型妈妈这有什么问题
我们讲这个护型投信
万般宠爱
一开始也没有问题
很好啦 其实他也是低档在接
很好 投信一路任养
任养到上面了
妈妈这个栽培小孩终于到了20岁了
该是放手的时候了
那这时候呢
你要进场
你要看
哇 股价高涨
你要看妈妈放手了没
对
头信假如没有再买的话
这个头信妈妈已经要放手了
对
那资党股票你就要小心
不是 妈妈放手
他为什么不能走自己的路啊
妈妈放手走自己的路
这个头信呢
他有时候放手
就一直放一直放一直放
股价可能就会跌下来
是 只要是用完了就对了
对 栽培大
开始钱搅过来
这个比较像是养一些食用性动物
养胖了就
养胖了可以
又是猪的话题
所以这边的话问题就是说
一路买 一路上
我们这边没有跟到
可能我们看到的时候
它其实要放手了
这要特别留意
对对对 它放手了
好
那投信连续11买好不好
赵小哥之前教的
其实投信连买应该是好啊
但是连11买会不会有刚刚的问题
他会不会买太久了
买太久
他已经赚够了
要放手了
那你要看他连11买
他买的张数多不多
还要看他怎么呵护的
对 怎么买的
搞不好只跟你滴水喝
对啊 搞不好像碎碎练型的
每天就给你碎碎练
唠叨没有重点
唠叨没重点
我最怕这种没重点的
讲话没重点
很恐怖
反而崩溃就对
对对对
那我们看这个
这个头信有重点吗
你看他连续11天买
买那么少
11天只买169张
169张
我们当中按下去就169了
这个根本不是投信的作为吧
只是那个人自己
他是常在投信吗
对 开心买买而已吧
对啊 这个张数太少了
所以这种连续11天买
你要看他买的张数
不要连续11天买
哇 很兴奋冲进去
结果后面点下来
好 所以连续买
可是买很少
就跟碎念没重点一样
对
太少张没重点
好
所以连续买
听起来到目前为止
连续买也是不好
连续买你要买的张数多
他可能放手
他可能买的很少
根本没有用
对
好
来吧
我知道观众最需要什么
我们最需要了解我们的妈妈
好
我们就要找有妈妈栽培的
有妈妈栽培的
小孩才有爆发力
好
这妈妈栽培多重
我们要看一个东西
叫投信买卖超占成交量比
好 投信的买卖超占成交量比
是指这一档个股的成交量
对 就当天的成交量
因为坊间一堆投本比
投信买卖超占股本比
投本比是占股本的意思
投信买卖超占股本
但这是占成交量 那要怎么说
它叫做投量比 对不对
对 这叫投量比
另外一种叫投本比
我觉得网友可能会在期待
我们讲出一些奇怪的名词
但是本节目啊
这一集挑战什么
因为要称赞妈妈
本一集没有颜色
没有颜色
如果任何你觉得有颜色
都是你们自己的看法
我们一直都没有颜色
我们一直都很清纯
对
好
外面都讲投本比
例如说台积电
2000多亿股本
那你投本比永远都上不了榜
没错啊
股本太大了
股本太大
有些大股东都不卖啊
张东某怎么可能卖
对不对
都不动的
那不动那投本比都很低
因为那股本太大
但是这实际上会影响股价的是成交量
所以如果台积电那么大股本
它一样可以从量来判断
对也可以
那你看我们用这个公式
投信买卖超出成交量就很简单
大于10%
那这种就是好的
好 这边投信买卖超是它的买卖超的金额
买卖超成交量
买卖超的张数吗
张数来处以量
上下的单位都一样
都是张数
连续两天以上会更好
好
连续两天以上有10%以上
因为一天可能是方任型的
那两天呢
这个妈妈这个正在关心中
这还不错
好
所以优点一呢
我们可以避开股票张数的盲点
好
优点二呢
显示投信照顾的决心
决心
因为连续买两天嘛
第三呢
股价处于低激起呢
爆发力就比较强
所以还是要配合股价
是不是还没有大涨
对不对
没错
大涨就要小心
好
所以这边在提醒大家
这是买卖超的张数
跟他成交的张数
对
不然
不是金额
我一直刚以为是金额
没有
像友达买3000张
哇好兴奋
好兴奋
哇就有那个成交量10万张
对
好像没那么兴奋
好
这个投量比很重要
对
好
有投量比的公司
大于10%连续两天
才会有好的结果
好 我们来看
有没有照顾呢
过往的案例
来 第一档 普瑞
普瑞在3月24号的时候
我们看这边
3月24号在这里
它的量
它的这个投信买了151张
其实从张数看会觉得很少
151张进不了榜
对
太少了
那成交量呢
991张
所以这个投量比一看
151除以991很简单 15%
其实很高
因为它是超级高价股了
它已经700多块了
那时候是500多块
所以它的张数不太可能多
所以就变成交量排行榜中的盲点
对不对
后面这个598涨到785
前面有买也有点
这是因为疫情的关系
疫情关系跌下来
后面这个创了新高
攻克武汉缺口
所以它是一个创新高的股票
所以有妈妈的公司
就算有疫情都不怕
都不怕
好
非常好
但是它太贵了
太贵了
对
就是我们没有喊金汤匙的
怎么办
我介绍你稍微便宜一点点
一厘厘
等一下这叫我便宜一点点
好不好
还是很贵
我们待会有更便宜的
来看第二个
这个富邦美
是
富邦美好像在这里讲富邦美
好像怪怪的
为什么呢
它不是你们的那个吗
没有没有
就是
你会觉得跟他对打的是
一个叫东森购物吗
东森电视已经没有股权的关系了
没有股权关系
所以就尽量推荐他没有关系
可以
来 捅捅一下
好 摸摸台
但是我觉得这比较特别
这养出来的是宅男宅女
真的吗
这妈妈养的小孩是宅男宅女
都在家里划手机
都不出去逛街
也蛮喜欢躺在床上购物的
划一划东西就送来
有时候很夸张
半夜在那边划
早上就送来
对啊
它六小时可以送
很恐怖
好
来看富邦美
富邦美在这地方
我们就可以看到
投信突然大买
都这么高了
还突然大买
刚开始
对
应该说这样子
横横来看的话
并没有到很高
对
突然大买
那我们看3月30号那天
成交让205张
对
投信买40张
40张怎么可能进榜
不可能
对不对
你看不到投信买超排行榜
对
可是40张就占了20%
后面股价从364张到498
不过小哥他这边有那么大一根
让人家看起来怕怕的
看起来怕
教你看很简单
这么大一根
有没有跌破他当初买的起涨点
你看这边卖这么多
可是这是累积的张数只是掉一点点而已所以因为这边多了买够多啊这边可能有一个投信就那边缺钱对慢一点慢一点
有人不知道交给哪一档股票缺钱嘛
可能是这样
那这没关系
后面还持续买
他一定会后悔的
他太早把他的孩子给
哦 这样子吗
交易出去
我不知道
不过这个富邦媒
他们这个时机买的不错
对
因为他们买在那个疫情
影响的时候嘛
对 然后因为宅经济
大家都觉得他一定受惠
其实业绩也果然是成长
对 没错啊
现在那个网络消费
这业绩蛮好的
好 还是太贵了
还太贵了
对啊
便宜的
对啊 你现在教我们
虽然说刚刚小哥有讲嘛
如果成交量排行榜里面
出现那种高价股
反而应该去关注
可是太贵了我们小股民
对啊
我都讲过啊 安丁
对
来啊来 安丁
优群
好 便宜一点了
好一点了
那这头信也买得很漂亮哦
对
你看他在这边大买
那大买的时候
我们看到成交量
一万两千多张
投信就买一千七百多张
买很多啊
投量比就有14%
14%就很多了
而且才刚买
连买第二天
但是他这边刚买的时候
有先做一个
好像小小的头就回档
稍微回档一下
回档测试这个低点
没有破
没有破就上去了
好
那这个买的时候
你看一下
这边又符合一个
我们之前讲的一个形态
什么形态
我们哪有讲形态
有有有
之前有讲的
那个叫什么
上轨翘
古民开心
今天没有颜色
越翘越开心
对吧
后面从72块涨到102块
好
所以这边
很强
所以我觉得这张图
带出我心里的一个疑问
对
就像刚刚
像有一根賣掉
你可以告訴我說
他前面買的夠多
賣掉一根還好
可是像這個要是我跟他
我會很沒有信心耶
因為我剛剛這樣買我跟
可是其實接下來是
可能被套
教你啊
你看你可以
你就知道他的成本在哪邊
等一下
來算成本
我的成本跟他一樣了
我成本跟他一樣
然後他又繼續買
還在買
開心
因為那時候他的籌碼比較集中
對
那這時候你成本跟他一樣
你追你也比較不用擔心
还有就是这里
小哥他连续卖卖卖卖卖卖
你可能这边你可以稍微出一些啊
我也跟着他卖就对了
我们都会讲你什么原因进场
对
你就什么原因出场
是这样子
好 但这不够
当然不够
你必须明确地告诉我
我什么时候妈妈要带我进场
我什么时候妈妈要带我出场
来吧 我给各位看一个
是不是
证券投资信托管理办法
这个管理办法可以教我
何时进场何时下车
对
哇 待进又待出
太刺激了吧
法规就告诉你
什么时候你该出场
对
我看法规怎么讲
每一个基金投资于
任一个上市或上位公司
股票的股份总额
对
不得超过该公司
以发行股份总数的10%
反正就是买一档公司
你不能占它股权超过10%
对
有些小公司真的投信买买
你就变它大股东
对 没错
那所经理的全部基金投资
也不得超过10%
这个有的大投信的话
旗下可能几十档基金
就真的很可怕
他们不能同时买同一家公司了
所以投信呢
其实投信占股本
在十几%已经算很高了
对
所以你看到十几%
你可能要准备测场
你说投信占这家公司的股本
如果超过十几%
就要很小心
对
你要小心一点
小心被当作被宰的孩子
投信下车了
妈妈也是要盈利的
跟孩子要费用
现在你长大了
就是孝庆费
我每年都会给
每年吗
不是每天都要给吗
小哥每天盘同交易
每年给一笔大的
然后每个月给工资
然后每天还会给零有钱
偶尔惊喜
对
想去买菜
其实我应该巴结小哥的妈妈
应该很有钱
还不错
那我们来看这个
什么时候进场
我们看投信刚买的时候
股价在低档
你可以进场
刚买的时候
对
那15比7%还好
我问细一点
有没有刚买几天
或刚买几根
连买两天最好
连买两天就可以了
可是连买两天
我怎么知道
它会不会是那种
真的就是照顾一下就跑的
连买两天
它连续信的几率
会比较高一点
你假如只买一天
有可能就买那天而已
好
连买两天
而且投量比要大于10%
对 股价在低档
OK
那等到高档的时候呢
你要注意看喔
投进要再下车
对
你就要跟着下车
可是
我可能到这边也觉得是高档
到这边也觉得高档
你只要看投进有连续卖超
连续卖超
这条线呢
开始往下降
OK
然后呢
这个投进持股比率又高
已经到17%咯
10%就不会买了
就不会买了
对呀
他们也赚够多了
他们要结账
好
所以他已经买到法规
可能已经是上限了
然後再加上它如果連續賣
像小哥有講
其實剛剛有一檔的例子是
連續賣它股價其實後面還有再上去
可是不要介意
因為我們不可能每個人都賺到薄薄薄
對 它連續賣我們就把它賣掉了
沒錯
好
那接下來教各位
怎麼找投量比啊
哇 這個在電視上都沒人看
沒人看
在網路上我們要好學不倦
我們要把它交完
因為今天讓大家等小哥最後就是你知道
這檔就是現在投量比
你們都在等這個嗎
滑到最后面就有了
滑到最后面就有
今天没有
今天没有颜色
也没有直接给你名牌
好
怎么找同样比呢
完了
现在大家已经急速
人数急速下降
好
Good Info
佛心网站又来了
这网站
这网站会不会讲了之后
它就当了
它还好
但是神秘金字塔会比较辛苦
上次真的当了
上次这个我们群主席
小哥那金字塔当掉了
神秘金字塔每次讲完都会当掉
每次讲完都会当
对
因为流量要费用啊
我觉得大家可能
就是如果有机会赞助
神秘金字塔就要赞助
因为经营网站流量
都是很高的费用
对 好
但是图人info没有当掉
没有当掉 好
它里面有很多资讯
其中有一个
法人买最多
哇 这个真的一目了然
对 点进去
法人买最多
好 点进去
点进去就了
点进去
法人买卖钞
这里有热门排行
法人买卖
好
那法人买卖呢
这里有投信买钞
战成交比
其实这就是投量比
对
投量比的概念
直接有一栏
对
点进去就可以看到了
我们看点进去长什么样子
点进去长这样
好
哇
好细耶
对啊
你看
对
投量比呢
这个当日买卖超战成交比
你看
我们说10%较高嘛
对
你看10%以上才9档而已
不是它32%是
对很多
三分之一被投信买走
对
这个买很多
风翔 健大 金华 拓凯 真顶 日油 台药 不方美
我发现如果说股价有这种破百的
也有四百的 也有二十七的
我是不是可以选这种便宜的就好了
可以啊 可以啊 你可以选便宜的
可以是不是 好
所以用这个看就比较客观一点
你假如每次电视上面看的都是张数
张数不客观
对 用这个看就不错
看你适合哪个价位 你可以去选
好 那刚刚有讲到有当日
两日 三日 它还到三年啊
对 投信会买三年吗
有这么长
他们有时候会做账
所以后面其实不大需要看那么多
好
不过你可以看这一段时间
有没有越买越多
哇 你看五日 三日 两日
这个
哇 这越买越多耶
买很多
对
好 那如果这一段时间看
当天的通常会多一些啦
哦 好所以就是如果它越买越多也是一個訊號對好 但是超過10天是不是小哥就不看啦小哥會卡在哪裡就是說因為他有當日二、三日
一直到三年
我就看到半年
半年的左邊就可以了
好 就半年之前的都還可以參考
半年之後的其實
媽媽不會
不會照顧你這麼久
沒說那麼長
大家要斷奶
對
OK
所以大家應該很容易找出來了
但是我知道小哥
因為你對你媽媽好
你也對你岳母很好
事實上你有兩個媽媽
所以兩個媽媽都在照顧你
對
這樣更好
對 你看照顧這樣
我結婚之後胖了20公斤
那是你老婆照顧的吧
岳母那邊也貢獻不少
滿會煮菜的
對啊 一年一公斤
好
幸好我們就是都一個老婆
配一個岳母這樣子
就20公斤了
好 我看
一眼找高投降比
这个是我设计的
加上主力买超
再加上主力买超
主力可能就是干妈或岳母
对 因为我们现在很怕
很怕投信被主力到货
因为刚刚有一个例子是
投信在买
可是中实户在卖
就中实户是赢的
对啊 那这种就不好
所以我们喜欢找
投信在买 主力也在买
两个妈妈都在养
对 这样比较安全
股价不会在高点
不会一个妈妈人前照顾你
一个妈妈人后下的手
对 对不对
所以这是好的
变静松片
好啦 来 这个投信
所以我们这边我们可以找
先找多方选股
好
筹码面我们找主力短多
我们就看到这边主力都在买
是
这些主一 主五 主十都在买
都在买
就一天的主力 五天的主力
十天的主力都在买
好
那投信呢
我们按照帕数排序
好
我们就可以找到一些股票
像昨天找的是
保雅 杰利 雍智 真顶
真顶又入榜了
真顶又出现了
等于是说
投信也买 主力也买
对
昨天这是真顶的盘中的走势图
那我们看真顶
真顶呢
这个是它的月线
真顶好像
才刚刚要涨的感觉
对 因为前面修正太多了
对 投信连买三天
好 三天
符合小哥觉得初期刚买
对 刚买
所以我们用这样子照
所以刚刚有想说投量比较10%
等于投信你有设一个门槛
可是主力买卖有没有什么
要买多少
还是有买就好
主力有在买就可以
好 有在买就可以
至少不会被到货
那当然数值越高越好
那这些都是主力有在买的
就比较安全
有在买就OK咯
主要是投量比较10%
但主力有帮着买就够了
好 我们来看
就他了
就把那个放大一点看
我们不是在推荐他
我们要特别讲
只是刚好他是一个入榜
我们这边要特别说
我们今天讲的个股
都是符合选股逻辑的
但是不是说就叫你买
然后买了后
有的观众很有趣
赚钱来谢谢我们也怕
当然如果让你赔钱
我们更不好意思
但是大部分都是赚钱
可是不要来谢谢我们
看看就好
因为是你学对了对的方法
不要追
双重呵护
就是主力有在买
好
头戏也在买
我们看5月5号那一天
昨天
成交量17000多张
投信就买2400张
好 大买
等于相对之下大买
成交比15%
15%
投量比15%
OK
所以这看起来好像还可以
我们就观察看看
观察
对
搞不好今天投信就卖了
有可能啊
真的有可能
我们为了小哥
我们可能要尽快让我们的作品上架
对对对
因为我讲的比较短一点
是
不像那个
不像古鱼
它真的超级长
看不到镜头
真的
好
我们上次那物片蛮有趣的
我们是很正常说的
上次那物片一堆人传截图给我
古鱼的截图
古鱼帮你看技术面跟筹码面
你帮古鱼分析基本面
对 他们说这部很有意思
他说这部我到底看了什么
好
除了真理外我们再来看巨大
巨大呢在4月28号
它的成交量4600多张
投信买了764张
投量比有到16%
巨大呢在这个时候
在这个时候投信买很多
那时候连续才买两天
它现在已经连续买六天了
像这个也是台股的基优股
就特别喜欢
它最近有在买
它又符合上轨翘
投信买 主力买
我很想开个玩笑
但我忍住了
你忍住 你要忍
你要忍
好
已经快到最后几张了
你叫忍好
大家自己猜
我本来想讲什么了
好
巨大
没有
好
你看第三档
也是双重客户幸福加倍
和论
这个我很有兴趣
和论你什么都知道
对
和论企业
那和论呢
我们看
他最近主力也在买
是
那4月27号那天
成交了2100张
是
投资买了240
40张
团比11%
11%也合格
10月27号
过关
现在呢
投资金连买六千
还在继续买
好
现行呢
看起来
这个也蛮漂亮的
还不错
对
好
最近真的做空不已
最近
最近很难空啊
对
我觉得真的
我们上次讲的主题是对的
就是台股多人运动的时候
真的有时候不能违逆这种现象
对
好
最近这个做空要小心
做空要小心
最近这个台股飙翻天
对
就是每一次都觉得说
应该要下来了
可是都没有
对
对 没错啊
所以我手上都有多单
我手上有空单嘛
但我一定会有多单保护一下
对
人家是空单保护多单
小哥是他的多单保护空单
空单最近没有那么多
好
以前比较多一点
好 今天我们做个总结吧
来 结论
来 第一个
投量比高的
要低档哦
低档比较好
低档投信布局股票
还没有涨很多的
值得留意
好
第二个呢
股价涨多
投信转卖
转卖你就要注意
因为他们股价涨多
投信一直买一直买
等它开始卖
可能会跌破
虽然这个涨多
可能有点抽象
但是总之它已经涨了
投信又在卖
那就不要留恋了
对 要记得获利了结
好 第三个呢
投信持有股票接近15%
15%就要小心了
很高了
就很高了
流星投信停止买信
停止买信
停止买信股价可能就盘了
又可能或者会跌
缺乏买信
那就要小心
所以虽然妈妈是爱我们
但是妈妈也不能都无条件的付出
儿子也要争气
对 没错
儿子如果争气的话
妈妈就会一直留在我们身边
恭喜你
恭喜我是不是
到现在为止都没有讲到任何
好 所以今天如果大家觉得赵华讲的话
有任何的颜色
真的都是你的想象
完全没有
对 我们今天这一集的话
是因为要因应母亲节
但是我觉得非常的应景
因为投信的买卖超
在最近一波台股的涨幅中
占了非常非常重要的角色
甚至什么外资啊
什么其实都不够力
反而投信是相对是比较准确
所以今天小哥教大家全套
就是投信如果在任养股票的时候
你要怎么做
不是每一种任养你都要跟哦
而且小哥还告诉你
最好你可以搭配什么呢
有没有干吗
如果主力一起来
两个一起养的话
这个孩子肯定白白又胖胖哦
那今天的歌友球必爆就到这边咯
我们下次再见咯
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜